the jurgen experience i think that's why
there's so much like distrust
in government and stuff now because
there's so many things that we realize
later on like
why was that so necessary well not only
that
i mean you're seeing it with this
administration where they're they're
doing the same things that trump was
doing
they're just pretending they're not he's
wearing cute jackets well it's just the
same [ __ ] thing like what they're
doing like
the whole thing was like the kids at the
border we gotta stop the
you know these families the boat with
this detention at the border putting
people in cages
they're doing the same [ __ ] thing and
then ted cruz went down the tr there to
try to film it and they were asking him
to stop filming like
this biden employees like stop filming
stop filming sir please
have some respect he's like this is like
you can't just
make rules like that we can't film now
and that's how you're gonna stop people
from talking about this
that nothing's changed because they were
pretending that trump was doing this
and that it was all trump's fault well
no it's the border
is crazy and porous and now that trump's
not in office
they think it's more friendly because
biden's there so more people are coming
through
and they have a lot of them have biden
t-shirts on have you seen that
no where they get detained yeah like
dozens and
they're going to a biden concert like
they're going to buy merch
we love you exactly help us you never
seen it you should see it it's crazy
so they're coming to the border wall
with biden shirts on
and so they've resumed construction of
the border wall well if you know that
so this company you know this
administration was like we're not going
to do what the
past administration did yeah you are but
is this going to be
huge
please let us in yeah biden please let
us
in look at this wow who's giving him
those [ __ ] shirts
probably the cartel they probably all
have a pound of kilos
a pound of coke in their ass
weird right yeah it's just a weird you
know what's even weirder i was talking
to a friend of mine
and he's much more knowledgeable about
this he goes you know listen man
he goes the bottom of mexico those other
south american countries they're trying
to get into mexico and the mexicans
don't want them coming into mexico
and then you got mexicans that are
trying to get into america and there's
americans who don't want them in
america like it's like they're doing it
too like it goes all the if you go down
to honduras and honduras and new mexico
they're like hey
you know we have enough like they're
literally it's happening
every step of the way up to america yeah
that's crazy i don't yeah i don't know
much about that
you don't pay attention well i just feel
like it becomes too
like like sighted like where
it's scary to talk about politics
because it can become so like if you say
one thing that's not with
you know some sort of like if it's not
in an infographic on instagram then it's
wrong
and it's all very like this way or that
way so i try and stay
somewhat informed but it just feels very
exhausting nowadays what do you mean if
it's on an
infograph i mean like i'm on very like
super
hyper woke instagram you know you are a
lot of
yeah a lot of my friends post a lot of
like you know woke [ __ ]
which you know do you yell at them for
that i scroll
past it i read it it's got shiny letters
and a nice font so i'm like oh this is
pretty but
it's it's very like extreme where it's
like you're either
all in or you're all out and i'm like
it's a bunch of people trying to control
people that's what it is mostly
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience